Greer couldn't reach that H holds the Zone
there's Harley who's been a big asset for
Dallas this year a back hit off the post
D will get it behind the net out of perms
way back to Marner got room to come out in
front improve the angle but the pass broke
it up see that fox collaps back to the
front just trying to protect that cross
seam CS kner white scores William
kner with a blast power play goal
Toronto well Chris maybe there's some of that
hesitation that the was talking about from his
penal Killers leaves did a good job of getting
control but there's no pressure at all there's
no stick in the passing Lane so this is a pre
pass across and then he pcket ends up actually
being a very very massive Dallas Stars penalty
kill six time the season that William nander
has opened the score there's a turnover and a
big stop by ssov with hits in front B back on
it hen at the line it's shot that ssov was moving
the other way and just reacted in the nick of top
they only played six games in the NHL last
year 34 in the NHL the year before so the
learning in the American Hockey League is paid
off last year fori a high sticking penalty and
a power play goal right off the Hop for JB Ben
well here's where Personnel really does make a
difference this is David Camp's face off pretty
much all day for Sheldon Keef instead you've
got neander cuz it's on the right side and so
good job by Dallas getting Jamie Ben on his
strong side he snaps it back and you can't have
a quicker executed well-run power play than that
one two passes and it's in the back of the net
you can see samsonov almost got a piece of it
was a pretty close call at the line too it would
have been interesting had it gone in thought it
might have been an offside but a move point now
here comes the do charging back into the middle
shoot scores and getting to up and Dallas has the
lead well you talk about getting a second chance
as he was unable to Coral that one earlier but a
turn over at the offensive line you know creates
this opportunity just to the outside a little
hesitation there by MCC that's a split second
decision can you close physically instead he goes
flying by see pretty comfortable playing on the
road here's Johnson back in W johnon Samson able
to fight that off Robertson across another porch
by the stars and Samson off will holded on to
the 10th shot by Gallas so one for one four for
their last six and looking for a equalizer here
tarz gets it started with a base off Wi neander
back to SP scores just like that 5 seconds in
and the leaps have a pair of Power Play Goals
and a tie well howo for John tarus went through
his career no points in nine games no goals in
10 the importance of a face off tarus just gets
another very passive penalty Kill by the Dallas
Stars and you know what that's a place that tarus
is so comfortable with you look at the goals that
he's across it comes to duen that broken up by
Matthews and here's Matthews working back got it
to Martyr here's martyr looking for a short-handed
goal and W what stops that to the Leafs have had
two scoring chances shorthanded in the game duain
comes back mder picks that off he'll go to the
attack again Matthews catching up it's Matthews
in and sto by webwood there's Marner crashing in
turning it over centering it and Matthews stopped
by Wedgewood on the doorsteps back to Morgan Riley
he's shot deflected and Matthews will whack at
the rebound hin paw for Dallas and Matthews takes
it away goes to the net it front scores [Music]
41st of the year on a forun is Bounce Lees have
the lead play retrieving the puck that is the
Difference Maker and this is what he does better
than most in the NHL doesn't take a penalty but
the quick active stick on hen PA turns the puck
over there's trying to slide it over to KN Lander
but it's that play there it just that timing of
your stick to make sure you don't take the penalty
to the sprawling Defender sometimes you got to get
a bit of a break you know just always seems to be
around it and just never seems to get rattled to
get into any kind of a pun here's a chance of
pzi can't get it by wwor left in front of the
net as the leads come close to adding to the
lead and the opposite end of that scale I mean
a frustrated has had so many chances like that
in back in the way Sams it on down and a stop on
S he'll send it off the in boards Sean left it for
duie Markman fires it across here's the shots SE
stopped and SS it up turn the wrong way doy with
13 points in 19 playoff games for Dallas here's
brusi to the reach ofne to bzi trying to make
sure they can pressure and get back into this
game and a set play a breakaway off a faceof
win and it'll draw a penalty and it'll draw
a penalty shot they're going to call a penalty
shot on the commercial break and everybody's not
really paying much attention you have a defensive
Zone face off and on a break beaten as Countryman
Woods let's see if he can do it again to tie it
and he does and getting toov second of the night
and now 12 on the year here's tonov afterwards
the end result is this just patiently Matthews
and N come back on Marner trying to get available
in front Matthews that wraparound try Marner gets
on it back to Matthews up top looks for martyr
off his feet to the net SC right back into the
lead off the Stick of Mitch marter wow little
WRA around now the puck in play but watch this
reception of the pass by Marner he gets knocked
down and gets into his skates he puffers in and
then just quick moves he gets the goal tender
to go down watch him skate to skate now he's
got control and in that tight all you're doing
is make sure you get it into the top third and
Wedgewood down low Marner with the quick
little release rolls in backto back GES
and goals in both against Dallas here's tarus
got KNE land to loose toar elander [Applause]
SC 20 seconds later it's 5
three the four four well how about that you
give up the lead and your four best players
offensively take it right back it's Matthews
toar the ship before toar was just an excellent
move that draws the defender in neander with the
quick release he plays he's Tamar has a forward
in r in rupe hins and it's Marr back around
for berzi and he'll swing it to the line but
not out henan to Marchman Mero hinan watch
byeri here's a shot scor Wyatt Johnson has
d within one that's exactly why those misses
just are so important obviously the two goal
lead the difference unable to get cleared and
good traffic in front you've got steel the dawn
off now it's just the dawn off and through
the body of Brody he's not able to get that
shooting Lane where does it go it goes right by
his glove and then samsonov didn't read it look
at the eyes of Sams he didn't read that till
late what a great pick up by Ben W he was the
only that saw the pucky got to it before it came
to the front of the net and the Le Hold On To Win
It